>> TREY: WELCOME BACK TO "SUNDAY
NIGHT IN AMERICA."
THIS EVENING, WE WANTED TO HEAR
FROM YOU, FROM AMERICA, SO WE
ASKED FOR YOUR QUESTIONS,
QUESTIONS ABOUT WASHINGTON, THE
DIRECTION OF OUR COUNTRY, WHERE
IT'S HEADED, WHATEVER IS ON YOUR
MIND.
BUT THIS IS OUR FIRST TIME, AND
IT WON'T BE OUR LAST, BUT IT IS
THE FIRST.
TOGETHER WE ARE WORKING TOWARD
THAT MORE PERFECT UNION.
OUR FIRST QUESTION IS FROM
MICHAEL FROM CHICAGO.
>> I'M ASSUMING MOST PEOPLE GO
INTO CONGRESS WITH A SET OF
IDEALS, OF MAKING COMPROMISES
AND COMPROMISE IS WHAT MADE OUR
NATION GREAT.
IT SEEMS WE'RE NOT DOING THAT
ANYMORE.
HOW DO WE GET BACK TO THAT?
>> TREY: IT IS TRUE, OUR COUNTRY
HAS A RICH HISTORY OF
COMPROMISE.
THE FACT THAT EACH STATE HAS TWO
SENATORS, WAS A COMPROMISE.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE WAS A
COMPROMISE.
SOME OF THOSE COMPROMISES WERE
GOOD.
AND SOME VERY MUCH WERE NOT.
IT IS TRUE THERE ARE MEMBERS NOW
WHO ARE MORE THAN WILLING TO
COMPROMISE TO GET THINGS DONE,
BUT NOT ON THE BIG ITEMS.
I THINK THAT'S TRUE FOR AT LEAST
TWO REASONS, PEOPLE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT GETTING A PRIMARY OPPONENT
AND COMPROMISE IS MORE OF A
GENERAL ELECTION ISSUE THAN A
PRIMARY ISSUE.
NUMBER TWO, THE DIFFERENCES SEEM
PRETTY STARK RIGHT NOW, IN TERMS
OF POLITICAL IDEOLOGY, AND
THERE'S A BELIEF AMONG SOME THAT
THE ISSUE IS BETTER THAN THE
SOLUTION, AND BY THAT I MEAN,
THERE'S A RELUCTANCE TO GIVE THE
OTHER SIDE ANY LEGISLATIVE
VICTORIES AT ALL.
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN LAST
SUMMER, THERE WERE ENOUGH VOTES
TO PASS TIM SCOTT'S POLICE
REFORM BILL, BUT THEY WERE NOT
GOING TO LET HIM HAVE A
LEGISLATIVE VICTORY PERIOD.
WHEN WILL THAT CHANGE?
WE CAN MAKE IT CHANGE.
THE QUESTION IS, YOU KNOW, WHEN
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER IN TERMS
OF PRIORITY, IN TERMS OF HOW YOU
VOTE, RIGHT NOW YOU CAN HAVE A
LONG AND VERY SUCCESSFUL CAREER
IN POLITICS WITHOUT EVER WORKING
WITH THE OTHER SIDE.
OUR NEXT QUESTION COMES FROM
TODD IN FLORIDA.
>> TERM LIMITS, IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S GOOD TO HAVE
NEW PEOPLE, FRESH IDEAS?
>> TREY: OBVIOUSLY I BELIEVE IN
THEM BECAUSE I TERM LIMITED
MYSELF.
I LEFT.
I WASN'T GOING TO LOSE.
I DIDN'T LEAVE TO RUN FOR
SOMETHING ELSE.
I JUST LEFT.
SO WHEN I HEAR TERM LIMITS, I
THINK TERM LIMITS ON PUBLIC
SERVICE, NOT JUST LIMITS ON ONE
OFFICE OR ANOTHER, AND HERE'S
WHY I SAY THAT, IF YOU LIMIT
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE TO THREE
TERMS, NOTHING WILL CHANGE IF
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO WIND UP
RUNNING FOR THE U.S. SENATE OR
GOVERNOR OR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE PURPOSE OF TERM LIMITS IS TO